on peut des concurrents avant la
signature d'un contrat quand le contrat
est signé c'est tout à fait différent il
est attribué il est signé dans ces cas
là les choses se passent un peu
différemment donc si vous voulez il faut
distinguer les étapes du dispositif mais
moi je soutiens qu'on est absolument
cocu dans cette affaire alors le titre
de votre émission va bien parce que à
qui la faute là je pense qu'il va
falloir décortiqué les opérations
et puis après en tirer des conséquences
mais pour répondre à la question qui est
posée à qui la faute si les torts sont
partagés
il faut identifier à quel moment on a eu
des avertissements il ya un rapport de
2020 des australiens qui explique qu'on
est en retard que la facture dérape et
c'est bon
donc ça c'est possible parce qu'on n'y a
pas fait assez attention que ça nos
services est ce que nos services de
renseignement n'ont absolument pas vu se
tricoter derrière leur dos c'est à dire
à notre nez à notre barbe un accord
important entre l'australie les états
unis et la grande bretagne parce qu'il
ya aussi c'est encore là qui s'est nouée
pendant ce temps là donc c'est pas
possible aujourd'hui qu'on arrive dans
cet état là sans avoir eu des
avertissements donc ça c'est la période
antérieure une fois qu'on aura identifié
ça il faudra prendre évidemment des
mesures nécessaires pour que ça se
reproduise pas alors il est intéressant
est intéressant c'est pour ne pas être
trahi par ses alliés il faut les trahir
le dire il faut espionner les
australiens pour savoir ce qu'il
concoctera
poche en poche on reproche à nos
services ce n'est pas avoir espionné les
appelait les australiens et les
américains
je dis pas ça comme ça je dis qu intel a
qu'un tel accord n'a pas pu passer
inaperçue
qu'on a des services qui sont faits pour
ça voilà donc je m'interroge simplement
je suis comme tout le monde je pose des
questions et tant que je n'aurai pas des
réponses et bien je serai toujours
interrogative alors persuadé que c'est
quand même pas dans une cour on n'est
pas dans une cour de récréation
[Musique]